quand le monde a besoin qu'on le sauve
il lui faut l'intervention de la
meilleure équipe d'élite de la planète
commandant kowalski rico soldats on
l'élargît élite de l'élite claquement
sec
par les créateurs de madagascar
ok ce coup là on y est les petits gars
cette mission s y est préparé et toute
notre but gardez votre calme et parfois
vous êtes maintenant sous la protection
du vent du nord soldats à l'habitat
mais il n'est pas question qu'on aille
avec boom
on sait même pas ce que vous faites dans
la vie le vent du nord est un commando
d'élite se traite un commando d'élite
secret un quart espace d'intervention
dont la vocation d'assister d'invoquer
la vocation d'assister les animaux qui
ne saute pas commandant on doit être
1,12 cent soixante mille pieds cela
restera quelque peu nos options
je crois que j'ai ma propre option
manoeuvre génial commandant mais il
semblerait que nous soyons à l'extérieur
de l'avion je me suis laissé emballer
par le feu de l'action avec le recul
bilan mitigé
pourquoi on ne prend pas cet avion là
impact volatiles noté l'oms
les pingouins de madagascar de
dreamworks
je suis d'accord on serait ou le 400 m à
300 m à tisser métriques torres kuyt
pardon chefferie 312,3 profil bon alors
là notre approche à l'opération est
évidente
[Musique]